what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys we are covering
Batman the Dawnbreaker the story where
Batman kills the DC Universe this is
absolutely bonkers but this is the first
audio that I'm recording after we got
back from New York comic-con man all the
members of the robbed core who showed up
do that okay so check out this video
check out this video real quick of like
everybody like the the huge crowd that
we got for the panel anyway the cool
thing about this is that initially like
what I will we first got up to the room
I saw like maybe 10 people and I was
like okay I mean that's cool you know
like we have to as I show up and as long
as I get to hang out with fans I don't
really care how many show up and then
like I turn a corner and there's like
200 people lined up and it was bonkers
because they all start change like rock
or rock or it was one of the coolest
things so we've got like the comic story
in core we've got the rod core we've got
the population from comic pop all just
gathered together in this massive room
and like it was so cool like it's so
humbling to see so many fans show up
it's it's god I never get past that and
I hope I never do I love meeting and
just like talking to fans like a regular
kind of a person like this is a regular
cover book fan Ethan Van Sciver the guy
who draws Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern Corps is part of the rob Corps
he got a round core ring like I gave him
one he told me to save one for him I was
like what no way I love you guys so much
I love hanging out with you guys it's
it's like meeting you guys it's like the
coolest thing ever
it's so awesome like you guys get
excited to meet me because you guys are
fans of me I love meeting you guys cuz
I'm fans of years so we're I'm a fan of
you guys it's always fun to hang out
with you guys to meet you guys but
anyway on to the story on to the whole
to the whole thing so Batman the
Dawnbreaker is one of these stories
where it almost draws unlike the idea of
parallax the old-school Hal Jordan
character well at the same time changing
things up a little bit differently but
initially what this does the way it's
written by Sam Humphreys is it hits the
most logical course it goes all the way
back to Joe Chill some guy who basically
shot Bruce Wayne's parents in a dark
alley and a mugging gone wrong and then
Bruce Wayne instead of just kind of
sitting there crying and then being
discovered by the police
feels like absolutely nothing
has no emotion whatsoever he falls fully
into this role of just being a sociopath
he doesn't feel anger he has a feel rage
as a feel fear he feels completely and
totally Hollow and in this lack of
feeling he suddenly met with a Green
Lantern ring which simply just comes
along and says you have the ability to
overcome great fear now this is the
caveat of the Lantern rings the Lantern
rings do not take your entire emotional
spectrum into account you know it's not
like you have the ability to overcome
great fear but you're kind of crazy so
like we're not gonna give you a ring it
doesn't work that way you have the
ability to overcome great fear welcome
to the Green Lantern Court that's the
only stipulation you need now
immediately grabbing this ring and
trying to kill Joe Chill this is where
things go bonkers because remember the
first rule of the Green Lantern Corps is
you cannot kill and that's initially
what holds Bruce Wayne back you are not
allowed to kill anybody you know lethal
force is not permitted and the ring
stops them Bruce Wayne's will overpowers
the programming of the Green Lantern
ring now I cannot even begin to tell you
guys how huge this is this is when we
start getting into parallax as far as
I'm aware the programming of the Ring
not allowing its wielder to kill people
was a Geoff Johns creation but it's
designed to ensure the Green Lantern
Corps exists as a peacekeeping force now
those are the guys who were at Jeff
John's Run which again you'll find all
those videos down on the playlist
recover him every Sunday one of the
things that was established was a
Sinestro Corps war the Sinestro Corps
led by thousand Estero waged war against
the Green Lantern's in response the
guardians of the universe the creators
of the Green Lantern rings removed this
rule and it allowed Green Lantern's to
kill in this universe that doesn't ever
seem to have happened Bruce Wayne
totally dominates the Wills programming
literally makes the ring his own and in
turn destroys Joe Chill now it's not the
first time that we've seen a person
overpower a Green Lantern ring we saw
that with Hal Jordan now the way it was
for years and years and years you know
really before Jeff Jones took over the
title it was just the idea that coast
city was destroyed and that Hal Jordan
basically just freaked out he lost his
money too started calling himself
parallax and in return he does
obliterated the Green Lantern Corps
killed all the guardians of the universe
except for ganthet who in turn took the
ring of Hal Jordan and then gave it to
Kyle Rayner and that's how Kyle later
became a Green Lantern in the Jeff Jones
however what we ended up finding out is
that when Hal Jordan started calling
himself parallax it's because he was
infected by the parallax entity when
Coast City had basically been destroyed
he felt fear and fear was able to
overcome his willpower and because fear
overcame his willpower it opened the
door for the parallax entity to go into
and to possess Hal Jordan which is why
he started calling himself parallax
it was a huge retcon but it worked
really really well in terms of how
parallax existed and so on in this
instance Bruce Wayne is not possessed by
the parallax entity Bruce Wayne is not
controlled by this living embodiment of
fear Bruce Wayne is just a kid who's
grieving over the death of his parents
and that's why this is so cool is
because there was a line there was an
argument that took place between Batman
and Superman in the injustice counties
and and Superman basically made the case
no matter what Batman does no matter
what Bruce Wayne does no matter what he
says no matter what steps he takes to
make Gotham a better place in every
single circumstance Bruce Wayne is
basically just still this little kid
crying in a dark alley because his
parents are dead this hits home to that
you sit down and you read a Batman comic
and you think about that force I can and
you realize when he's fighting the Joker
when he's fighting the penguin when
Jason Todd is killed by the Joker
you know when Tim Drake becomes Robin
when Nightwing takes off and says I'm
becoming my own character now you know
no matter what it is that happens every
instance of Bruce Wayne getting angry
whenever he's fighting as a hero he's
still just this little kid crying over
the death of his parents because that's
the motivation for him now the other
half of this is that Sam Humphreys kind
of teases this extreme power of Bruce
Wayne with a Green Lantern ring because
what he ends up doing is actually
resurrecting his parents from the dead
now of course they immediately go back
to being dead after he realizes he can't
return them to the way they work but
we've never seen an instance where a
Green Lantern ring has been able to
resurrect somebody from the dead we've
never seen a person who is able to
dominate the extreme power of a Green
Lantern ring and in turn resurrect the
dead now what this does is it basically
hits home and it offers an indirect
bolstering to the power of the Green
Lantern's and again that's how these
stories work a person who is never
originally part of the Green Lantern
Corps person who does not exist in the
main DC Universe a person in some story
off out in the middle of nowhere will
suddenly get a Green Lantern ring and
they'll do something with that ring that
we've never seen done before and then
suddenly that becomes a state
suddenly it becomes well maybe somebody
could do that later on down to one if
this creates a precedent then it means
that now in the main DC line of stories
we could suddenly see how Jordan just
continued to advance his own willpower
to the point that he can resurrect
people from the dead
again Guinea back into the story the
whole idea is that with Bruce Wayne
having a Green Lantern ring suddenly he
just begins dominating and killing every
single villain he comes across now this
is one of the things that I like about
this version of Bruce Wayne what all
these villains have shown is that
they're incorrigible they're unwilling
to change the things they do result in
the deaths of countless people whether
it's through peddling substances
robberies different things like that or
just having people taken out because
they're opposition whatever the case may
be he just keeps going through and
taking all these guys out now we see
these as somewhat of a flashback when he
kills scarecrow when he kills the
penguin we see these as flashbacks
because he's literally talking to Jim
Gordon and while the Gotham police
department is terrified of this teenage
Bruce Wayne what they basically come to
terms with is the idea that people are
missing around Gotham City criminals are
just vanishing left and right and no one
knows why but Jim Gordon suspects that
Bruce Wayne is the one who's doing it
and that's what he does he confronts
them with this information is this why
are you doing this now
the other half of this is the other part
of the power that Bruce Wayne's created
for himself again when it comes to the
Green Lantern mythos their ability to
create constructs is directly
proportional to how confident they are
in themselves as well as their ability
to control the green part of the
emotional spectrum the will aspect of
the emotional spectrum and so with Bruce
Wayne because his will is so extreme he
in turn is not only able to create
constructs he actually creates
constructs that are part of himself now
again this is a stark difference from
what we've seen before because we've
seen Batman with a Green Lantern ring
before the Hal Jordan gives Bruce Wayne
his Green Lantern ring it says just use
it see if you can pull it off and in
this story Batman uses the ring and is
able to conjure constructs of his
parents but it's wildly difficult to do
but in this instance you know in this
alternate universe story when he's
younger when he's a kid in the emotion
of his parents die the total sadness
that he feels his willpower to basically
fix everything is extreme and the reason
why is because this hits at how Bruce
Wayne used to be versus how he is now
over the years Bruce Wayne in the way he
functions is a reflection of his wisdom
as a reflection of the fact that
sometimes you can't just go in guns
blazing sometimes it's more about
politics than it is about running in and
just beating up the bad guy now over the
years he's learned finesse
he's learned that you have to have a
little bit of guile if you want to
achieve your goals in this instance he
is a teenager he's a young man whose
parents were killed as a kid he was
basically given miss godly power and in
turn between his imagination between the
fact that he wants everyone to suffer
the way he does he literally takes this
emotional spectrum and just kind of
merges it with his own soul and he
creates these sort of hybrid constructs
where it's basically referred to you as
the darkness but it's the darkness and
Batman's soul and so it's almost asking
the question what would happen if Bruce
Wayne's Hollow nature were to pollute
the emotional spectrum then what would
take place well that question is
answered when you know after it is that
he kills Commissioner Gordon he's
immediately met by the Guardian to the
universe and the Green Lantern Corps and
what he does is literally just initiate
this blackout and these constructs that
he's created in this void of his own
soul are virtually indestructible it's
almost like whisking a person off to
another dimension and it's absolutely
insane because while we don't
necessarily see what happens we
basically end up finding out that these
constructs he's created obliterate the
guardians of the universe
they obliterate the Green Lantern Corps
everyone is completely destroyed and so
going forward he simply just starts
calling himself the dawn breaker now
this is crazy because the guardians of
the universe are insanely powerful I
mean they are some of the most powerful
beings in existence it would literally
take somebody channelling the entirety
of the emotional spectrum in order to be
able to take them out and that's what
Bruce Wayne's doing again the idea here
this statement made by the guardians of
the universe is you have to stop what
you're doing is polluting the emotional
spectrum and that's exactly what he's
done it's taking ink and putting it in
and you're putting a drop of it in a
beaker of water it's just gonna spread
it's just gonna go everywhere eventually
it's just going to be nothing but
darkness inside that beaker that ink
will basically taint that water
forevermore and that's what they're
saying here is that he's just polluting
that aspect of the emotional spectrum
he's going to destroy everything now of
course this coincides with the beginning
of the destruction of his own earth and
this is when we basically started
hitting into this idea that when it
comes to these alternate reality
versions of Batman their universes are
being totally obliterated but for
reasons that we haven't fully fleshed
out yet it is believed that like these
finite laws of the universe are being
broken that the destruction of these
universes are because of the fact that
these different versions of Bruce Wayne
are doing things they're not
most to and so again it's kind of cool
but we actually end up picking up with
the man who laughs for this joke Erised
version of Batman he looks amazing I
just want to say that he looks so
awesome
you know he looks you look so cool here
but it's basically this idea of saying I
am recruiting people for Barbados
building up the ranks building up all
these different folks now again this
seems to have taken place long before
the events of like Dark Knight's Forge
the casting but building up these
rosters literally leads to Dawnbreaker
Batman showing up in the DC Universe now
one of the other things that I wanted to
hold off until this very point are the
nature of these worlds that these evil
versions of Batman are coming from and
think about the DC multiverse and terms
are just the numbering think about it is
like a number short right like you've
got zero in the middle and then you've
got one two three four going to the
positive side and then you've got
negative one negative two negative three
negative four going to the negative side
but what DC is doing is they're building
up earth Prime in the DC universe which
is to say the stories you've been
reading since the new 52 first started
they're building that up is like the
center point of the entire multiverse it
is the singular middle point at which
everything branches out and so what it
does is it would literally allow a
person to enter into this world and then
by extension enter into other worlds you
know so it's like walking into a room
with a room full of doors you know it's
interesting in terms of how that happens
but the idea here is that him facing off
against Hal Jordan shows him arriving
with powers that Hal Jordans never seen
before and that the ring cannot
interpret the knowledge of a Green
Lantern ring is contextual and is
basically limited to the universe in
which that Green Lantern ring was
created and so because of that the Green
Lantern ring that Hal Jordan wheels does
not know anything about the constructs
that Bruce Wayne wields because they're
not from the universe or Hal Jordans
ring came from and so again that's why
this works because it basically hits
home with this idea that now it's going
to be this mad dash to figure out
exactly how his constructs work what the
weakness of his constructs are and how
those constructs can be defeated but
again it's basically this Green Lantern
Batman from an alternate reality popping
up in the DC rebirth universe and then
just immediately dominating Hal Jordan
but again much like we saw with Red
Death dr. fate pops up and whisks him
away now keep in mind dr. fade is like
the Doctor Strange so to speak of the DC
Universe may dr. fate predates dr.
strange but in terms of the
roles they play dr. fate is really more
of these guys where he just kind of
watches everything unfold and then
simply says okay either I'm going to
intervene on behalf of the fates or I'm
not going to intervene because the fates
don't want me to but in this instance is
him basically whisking Hal Jordan away
and saying yes you're gonna have to live
to the destruction of Co City all over
again but you are needed elsewhere
what this does is it teases the
possibility of the return of parallax
Hal Jordan because remember the original
parallax Hal Jordan popped up because of
the fact that coast city was destroyed
if DC ends up deciding is just like make
parallax Hal Jordan this would be the
time to do it now I don't see DC doing
the same gag twice I mean it's just
wishful thinking on my part I really
wish it would happen but the cool thing
is here in this instance is basically
the entirety of Ko city being covered in
darkness basically being whisked away to
this dimension Dawnbreaker Batman had
created in his own universe so again
it's pretty wild Dark Knight's Medal huh
best thing to come out of DC rebirth it
is amazing anyway guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob port if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later please
[Music]